Ist es vielleicht nur ein zufälliges Rauschen
oder handelt es sich tatsächlich um die Spuren
eines Schwarzen Lochs, das aus einem anderen
Universum stammt?
Ein internationales Forschungsteam ist sich
sicher, den “Geist” eines Schwarzen Lochs
aufgespürt zu haben.
Dieses könnte demnach aus einem anderen Universum
stammen und schon längst verschwunden sein?
WHAT?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Man kann es vielleicht mit manchen Sternen
vergleichen, die wir zwar von der Erde aus
sehen, die aber schon längst nicht mehr existieren.
Ein Forschungsteam der Universität Warschau,
der Oxford University und dem New Yorker Maritime
College will jetzt quasi den “Geist” eines
Schwarzen Lochs aufgespürt haben.
Dieses muss nach Ansicht der Fachleute aus
einem anderen Universum stammen und längst
wieder verschwunden sein.
Deswegen handelt es sich auch nur noch um
den “Geist des Schwarzen Lochs.
Gab es möglicherweise vor uns also bereits
andere Universen, die ebenfalls wie “unser”
Universum zahlreiche Schwarze Löcher enthalten
haben?
Und ist es sogar möglich, Spuren dieser längst
verschwundenen Schwarzen Löcher aufspüren?!
Das Forschungsteam beruft sich bei dieser
verblüffenden Hypothese auf die sogenannten
“Hawking-Points”, die das mysteriöse
Schwarze Loch als Spuren hinterlassen habe.
Dabei soll es sich vereinfacht gesagt um Stellen
handeln, an denen noch Überreste der Hawking-Strahlung
vermutet wird.
Stephen Hawking selbst hatte erkannt, dass
die oft als Staubsauger bezeichneten Schwarzen
Löcher nicht nur Materie verschlucken.
Bis dahin nahm die Fachwelt an, dass Schwarzen
Löchern nichts, einfach gar nicht entkommen
kann.
Doch der Physiker zeigte, dass sie Strahlung
aussenden und letztendlich langsam verdampfen,
bis sie dann irgendwann verschwunden sind.
Heißt also: Schwarze Löcher halten nicht
bis in alle Ewigkeit.
Und das waren tatsächlich nicht nur überraschende,
sondern sogar revolutionäre Erkenntnisse!
Diese Strahlung wurde dann einige Zeit später
als “Hawking-Strahlung” bezeichnet.
Die Fachleute, die den Geist des mysteriösen
Schwarzen Lochs aufgespürt haben wollen,
gehen von den folgenden Annahmen aus.
Sie sind der Ansicht, dass Schwarze Löcher
die Masse des Universums aufsaugen UND Teilchen
abgeben, die über keine Masse verfügen - sogenannte
Gravitonen und Photonen.
Diese masselosen Teilchen zeichnen sich dadurch
aus, dass sie sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
bewegen und Raum und Zeit nicht wahrnehmen.
Irgendwann besteht dieser Theorie zufolge
das ganze Universum nur noch aus diesen speziellen
Teilchen.
Dann sei der Zeitpunkt gekommen, an dem ein
neues Universum entsteht.
Doch die Hawking-Strahlung sei in diesem neu
gebildeten Universum als Überrest des alten
Universums noch messbar.
Dahinter steckt also die Annahme, dass die
Hintergrundstrahlung eines zerfallenden Loches
auch noch dann vorhanden ist, wenn ein Universum
endet und ein neues Universum beginnt.
Das Universum, aus dem das längst verschwundene
Schwarze Loch stammen soll, könnte nach Angaben
deutlich älter sein als das Universum, in
dem wir gerade leben.
Die Fachleute spekulieren, dass es sich zudem
auch noch anderweitig von unserer Universum-Version
unterscheiden könnte.
Sogenannte kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung
führte die Fachleute auf ihre Spur.
Diese Strahlung, in der Fachsprache auch als
“Cosmic Microwave Background” (CMB) bezeichnet,
existiert wohl schon seit dem Zeitpunkt kurz
nach dem Urknall.
Das Schwarze Loch soll diese spezielle Strahlung
hinterlassen haben.
Ein Forscher, der an dieser Untersuchung beteiligt
war, ist Roger Penrose.
Er war ein wichtiger Mitarbeiter von Stephen
Hawking und ist zudem ein Verfechter einer
modifizierten Versions des Urknalls. 2010
hat er die sogenannte Hypothese der “Konformen
Zyklischen Kosmologie” aufgestellt.
Demnach bedeutet das Ende des einen Universum
der Beginn des nächsten Universums.
Dabei hinterlassen Schwarze Löcher ihre Spuren
in den folgenden Universen.
Penrose beschreibt seine Entdeckung folgendermaßen:
“Es ist nicht die Singularität des Schwarzen
Lochs oder sein tatsächlicher physischer
Körper, sondern die gesamte Hawking-Strahlung
des Lochs während seiner gesamten Geschichte.
”Demnach handelt es sich bei den nun entdeckten
Spuren also gar nicht um ein Schwarzes Loch
an sich, sondern um sein Bestreben über Milliarden
Jahre hinweg, die Energie in Form von Hawking-Strahlung
an das Universum abzugeben.
Das Schwarze Loch hat sich dadurch Stück
für Stück aufgelöst und dabei Spuren hinterlassen.
Dabei entstanden ist eine Markierung, die
den Tod des jeweiligen Universums übersteht
und sich in der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung
niederschlägt.
Das Forschungsteam will seine Hypothese mit
einer gefälschten Karte untermauern, die
zufällig generierte Hintergrundstrahlung
zeigt.
Mit deren Hilfe haben die Experten versucht,
ähnliche Punkte im Universum zu reproduzieren.
Doch diese zufälligen Daten bildeten das
Phänomen nicht nach.
Damit sehen die beteiligten Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler ihre Hypothese gestützt.
Doch unter Experten ist der aktuelle Aufsatz
durchaus umstritten.
Laut Kritikerinnen und Kritikern kann es nämlich
nicht ausgeschlossen werden, dass es sich
stattdessen um eine zufällige Zerstreuung
kosmischer Hintergrundstrahlung handelt.
Wow, kann ich da nur sagen.
Das ist extrem spannend!
Hawkingstrahlung nachgewiesen?
Hier gehe ich nochmal detailliert auf diese
Mysteriöse Strahlung.
Anklicken, anschauen und Clixoom Science & Fiction
abonnieren und die Glocke nicht vergessen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!